TO MASSACHUSETTS AND SAYS,
I'M GONNA DEAL WITH THESE LAWS
TO THEIR BLOODY FACE.
OR I'M GONNA BLOODY DEAL
WITH THESE LAWS
IN THE FACE.
IN OTHER WORDS,
I'M CONFRONTING THIS [bleep]
HEAD-[bleep]-ON.
HONESTLY,
LAYING ON THE FLOOR LIKE THIS
IS ONE OF THE BEST TIMES
I'VE HAD IN A LONG TIME.
- [laughing]
- SO MARY--SHE'S VISITING
QUAKERS IN PRISON.
THEY WERE LIKE,
THANK YOU, MARY, FOR COMING,
'CAUSE WE GET THAT YOU GET
WHAT WE'RE GOING THROUGH.
SHE'S LIKE, TOTALLY.
SO THE COMMONWEALTH
OF MASSACHUSETTS
WAS LIKE,
STOP VISITING PRISONERS.
STOP ACTING LIKE
IT'S OKAY.
WE GOTTA [bleep] KILL YOU.
SO HE WALKED HER
TO THE GALLOWS
ON BOSTON COMMON
IN 1660.
AND THEY PUT THE NOOSE
AROUND HER NECK.
SO SHE HAD THE ROPE
AROUND HER NECK,
LIKE, ABOUT TO DIE.
SHE SAID,
NO EAR CAN HEAR,
NO TONGUE CAN TASTE,
NO HEART CAN UNDERSTAND...
THE JOY--
SOMETHING LIKE, THE JOY--
[bleep].
I DON'T [bleep] KNOW.
THE JOY AND THE TREASURES
OF THE BLESSINGS
AND THE REFRESHMENTS.
I DON'T GET WHAT THAT IS.
BUT THE REFRESHMENTS OF GOD
THAT I HAVE,
STARTING RIGHT THIS [bleep] NOW.
[triumphant music]
♪
EVERYONE'S WATCHING.
THEY'RE LIKE,
OH, MY GOD.
WE'RE ON THE BOSTON COMMON.
WE'RE ON--
WATCHING SOMEONE DIE.
THAT'S YOUR PROBLEM
FOR BEING A SICK [bleep].
AND THEN KING CHARLES
WAS LIKE,
EXCUSE ME, WHAT THE [bleep]
IS EVERYONE DOING
OVER AT MASSACHUSETTS?
I DIDN'T SAY THIS [bleep]
SHOULD GET SO CRAZY.
DON'T KILL PEOPLE.
THAT MAKES YOU LOOK MORE
LIKE A PUSSY,
IF YOU DIDN'T KNOW,
BY THE WAY, DUDES.
BUT SHE CHANGED THE WORLD.
BUT YOU'LL NEVER HEAR ABOUT IT
ANYWHERE BUT HERE.
- WELL, NOW--
- [crying]
SHE'S IN AN UNMARKED GRAVE
ON THE BOSTON COMMON.
AND YOU KNOW WHOSE GRAVE
IS MARKED?
[bleep] JIM MORRISON.
PEOPLE FLY TO EUROPE
TO SEE IT.
AND HE WROTE HORRIBLE MUSIC.
[patriotic music]